so today I have the biggest TV that I've
ever unboxed in my living room right now
like I am so shook even the guy that
delivered this had to double check I was
sure that I knew what I was getting
myself into I was like yep we got this
so here it is this is the TCL 98 in qm8
TV a huge thank you to TCL for
partnering with me on this video one of
the reasons that I'm so excited about
this is obviously I've never reviewed a
television this large but I really want
to see if the quality holds up with a
screen this large so first things first
we've got to unbox it
so it looks like we just got to FP this
off now I have reviewed a lot of
different types of TVs but never won
this large so I was so hyped to check
this out and see how it holds up in
terms of quality this is the stand and
we've got some
cables they have the setup so it's
really easy to put the legs on you just
cut this away take the foam and then pop
on the
legs usually on a lot of large TVs like
this you have to lay it down on a couch
or on a bed but this is so large like I
was dreading that so thankfully they
have this foam set up in a way that it's
actually a stand this will let us easily
put these legs on without having to risk
damaging the front of the screen I was
also excited to learn that TCL is the
number one brand for 98 in TVs globally
so my expectations are pretty high okay
both legs are on are you ready for your
new
home I'm not going to lie that was
really
heavy this is the topof the line TV that
takes the home theater experience to an
entirely new level letting us at home
replicate the same cinematic field of
view found in theaters without worrying
about viewing distance so everything's
all unboxed it's plugged in and now it's
time to turn it on and set it up so
since this is a Google enabled TV I am
setting this up to work with Google
voice activations so that's pretty cool
okay Google what's the weather tomorrow
set a timer for 5 minutes hey Google
make a call remind me to water my plants
every
Monday
[Music]
drum roll please the apps are installing
I basically picked all of the apps that
I possibly could so this may take a
second or
longer so the setup on this was super
simple I used Google home to
automatically sign me in download My
Apps and as soon as it was done
basically everything was all logged in
my apps were here and now it's time to
watch some content
wow
it's it feels like I'm there it feels
like I am the Drone this is massive if I
get a little bit closer I don't even
think I'll realize that I'm not in my
home right now like I'm sitting less
than 10 feet from a 98 in screen and it
looks amazing Maddie what do you think
the TCL 98 in qm8 TV features tcl's
Quantum do Q LED technology with ultra
wide color gamut providing over a
billion colors for for richer and more
lifelike images this is so perfect for
everything from live sports
action-packed movies and even fast-paced
video games which I love with
industry-leading mini LED Ultra
technology allowing up to 2300 plus
local dimming zones and precise Zone
control with full array Ultra local
dimming this will give you the most
accurate representation of an image it's
so crazy like this TV is so massive like
it doesn't even feel real like this
feels like a like I'm at a movie theater
right now
it looks so good it's pretty cool
because TCL is the official TV of the
NFL so this obviously is something that
would be incredible to watch sports on
and you know what else TCL is the
official TV of Call of Duty which is one
of my favorite games so I'm so excited
about this so now I think it's the
perfect time to switch to Game Mode I
have never played video games on a TV
this large so this is going to be quite
the experience I just switched the input
to my Xbox and this mode automatically
came up this is the exclusive mode for
gaming and and it says that it has been
enabled so here's the game mode
interface which is kind of cool because
I can take screenshots you can change
the game picture mode so you can change
it from the original to first person
shooter or to RPG we've also got a
shadow enhancer aiming Aid and inside of
the menu we have some additional options
for HDR if you want the game bar to be
hidden while you're taking a screenshot
and even some aiming Aid settings up at
the top we'll give you all of your
different settings and let you know
what's happening so you've got your
frame rate your HDR your Alm and your
vrr with t ccl's exciting new game
accelerator 240 feature this allows for
super fast 240 vrr gaming Plus Auto game
mode which dare I say makes this a true
game Cher qm8 also includes a native 120
HZ panel refresh rate and motion rate
480 with MMC frame insertion yields for
best-in-class motion Clarity which is
perfect for action-packed movies and
live sports with ultra smooth viewing
with this premium model TCL has also
received its first IMAX enhanced
certification for the Q7 and qm8 series
for meeting High requirements in
resolution contrast brightness color and
sound for movies as well as AMD
certification for gaming with free sync
premium Pro the TCL qm8 also has HDR
Ultra Dolby Atmos and DTS virtual X for
premium picture and audio in addition
qm8 features enhanced audio with a
built-in subwoofer Wi-Fi 6 for improved
connectivity a hands-free voice control
and backlit voice remotes Bluetooth
connections four high-speed HDMI input
This TV has been so much fun to check
out and I cannot wait to continue
watching it and testing it out more
playing games on it was absolutely such
an incredible experience I mean it
basically was like going to the movie
theater and bringing my console and
video games with me but instead I'm here
at my house now I know a lot of people
do worry about controller and input lag
and obviously you know when you are
playing on smaller displays there is a
huge difference but I was still
surprised that I was still able to play
Call of Duty and it felt really smooth
and seamless just like I normally am
used to and again the picture quality is
still super impressive and especially on
such a large TV my main question was
what is the quality going to look like
because it is so massive what's that
upscaling going to be like how is the
content going to look and I was
pleasantly surprised with not only how
movie trailers TV shows Sports and even
my own YouTube videos looked on it
pretty awesome again this was so much
fun to check out and this is tcl's
largest qclass TV and I love that this
replicates the same cinematic field of
view found in theaters so it really does
make it feel like an entirely new world
if you want to get more info or purchase
you can get your premium TCL 98in qm8 TV
on sale at Best Buy for Black Friday for
59.99 now this sale is actually going on
right now and Best Buy is offering free
installation through December 3rd so be
sure to check it out thank you guys
again for watching and I hope you guys
have a happy holiday it's almost the
holiday season see you